do you feel sad
do i is this going to make me snack yeah
100
it's going to snatch the snatch the
house down gwyneth paltrow is learning a
thing or two from her 17 year old
daughter and let's just say she is here
to slay it was so fun i loved it the
goop founder is one of the lucky few who
received a skim's pr box from kim
kardashian's latest collab with fendi
and having no unboxing experience gwen
tapped her daughter apple martin for
some help
oh
that's apple's voice behind the camera
little bra
very little
is this how you do an unboxing yeah
it's gonna teach me my way look it up
see doesn't that look nice
and while explaining the purpose of a
bodysuit the teen teaches her mom a new
word to add to her vocabulary what is
that this is so you can get nice and
snatched so this is snatched
do you feel snatched do i is this going
to make me snap yeah 100
it's going to snatch the snatch the
house down gwyneth proudly captions the
clip quote i have now learned that
snatched means i am killing it of course
this isn't the first time apple
collaborated on a video with her mom
back in april the 17 year old trolled
gwen on tick tock i suppose the goop
glow is a part of her cleanse which
she's been on since the day i was born
apparently while starring in a video for
her mom's company goop apple described
what she thinks her mom's morning
routine looks like so first my mom
drinks her
goop glove super powder and
she eats nothing except for dates and
almond butter so she will have that and
after all of that the teen says her mom
does work hard yeah then she gets to
work making some more vagina eggs and
candles
also vagina candles
and vagina perfumes and
just everything vagina um and yeah
that's my mom's morning routine but at
the end of the day it was all for fun
the brand captioned the video quote when
you get roasted by your gen z daughter
it was pretty crazy and it's no surprise
the mother daughter duo is so close
while chatting with e.t about her new
netflix series sex love and goop the
actress revealed the relationship advice
she shares with her teenage kids i think
the main thing and you know that nobody
ever tells you is like you have to stay
really close to your own truth and you
have to stay really in integrity with
that truth because
you know when you're in a relationship
and you're not being your full self
um
you're sublimating things or you're like
white knuckling through something it's
actually i i think it's it can be pretty
damaging on um how you feel about
yourself and
so i will always just encourage my
children to really listen to themselves
like listen to their instincts listen to
if something feels right or not right
and to act from that place